all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibantas ty guy travis that
thursday evening camp fire goodness is
back let's start off with ibontis the
cheetah how we doing sir uh well shout
out to our first super chat of the night
two dollars from xeno1121. lovecraft
country owns all that is actually the
lovecraft show that i couldn't think of
uh what was it i think hbo maybe yeah i
remember that being a thing um
no duh got just been kind of a busy week
still
you know
getting up a little early walking all
three of our dogs early in the morning
because man i was just standing outside
as i let we have that you know new
one-year-old dog and trying to walk them
but i was just standing outside letting
them outside at like three o'clock in
the afternoon i'm just we're cooking
down here in texas but i think the whole
country is right now everybody's yeah
pretty much on fire unless maybe you
live in san francisco i don't know what
your guys weather is like right now but
florida 62
degrees screw it
it's always 62 here yeah
we don't have seasons
yeah
okay okay
absolutely what do you got what's your
what's your forecast i was like i'm
literally looking it up uh it's one of
those where it's 101 for a high and the
heat index is like 107. the problem with
dallas
is when we get to a summer like this
every so often we'll have
ones where it's a little less or a
little more um but the idea is the low
is 80.
so if you want your house to be a
reasonable temperature it literally the
ac never turns off i mean it'll kind of
do it's like cycling off and on thing
but the low
is 80. it doesn't get below that
my god that honestly if it ever was 101
degrees in san francisco i would move
that day
i would be packing my bags i cannot deal
with that weather i think the hottest
it's ever been here is like 78 and that
was really uncomfortable also people who
live in other places find it super weird
that i don't have an air conditioner in
my house no because i've never i've
never needed one yeah in fact you're not
even allowed to have an air conditioner
in my neighborhood because it's
considered a waste of energy because i
live surrounded by the ocean at all
sides so if it's cold if it's too warm i
just open a window and you get oceans
it's gonna be cool yeah yeah it's
completely pointless but yeah i mean
that would be nice but yeah here in the
middle i mean that's the other thing too
is you get more and more like concrete
and streets and everything it's just
like the whole area just soaks in heat
and then it just keeps it so just the
whole air is just the cycle of heat that
rotates
so we'll see if the electric grid holds
up but you know i've been playing some
destiny got the new story in got my big
guide out for duality if you guys
haven't seen that one i went through for
the the everyman build there are faster
ways to do it but i went through with
all legendaries so if i can do with my
crappy loadout you guys can do with a
lot of better stuff so that was good
um thank you guys for the bobble head
video views those have been just
slightly popping off they're short and
sweet but little collectibles yeah it
was like you were doing that yeah just
about the collectibles every week the
bobble head and the automaton um
yeah just they've actually been pretty
well but no cal is showing doing good
yeah those are not bad and then other
than that i'm just trying to trying to
find a time to balance
with the dog and then i want to get back
into just some of the other variety
stuff because i'm trying to get some of
that stuff in because i saw a tweet
today of what october looks like in
october looks like it's going to be a
pretty stacked month in there as well so
i'm looking forward to
a lot uh also work on scheduling us some
fun guests you guys will
i might get cooking yeah i might get a
might get a schedule out if i can get
like all the way through july scheduled
i got one more slot to fill if i get
that filled i'll get you guys to
schedule out and we got like we got a
lineup coming up for like the next five
or six weeks i got a couple others in
the works so a lot of good ones coming
so make sure you guys spread the word
big guests um very excited about some of
these we got coming up for you guys so
that's mostly what i've been working on
travis you uh burning the candle at
every end possible to write reviews and
games yeah i am yeah i've got a whole
bunch of ign content coming up um my
review of outriders world slayer is
gonna be live on monday morning i'm
tuning in yeah i just i started a little
preview there there too oh yeah i did
the preview finished it over the um
finished it over the weekend and uh
yeah it's too bad you weren't free i had
extra codes you could have played with
me but anyway we got through uh we got
through that uh that game and it was a
lot of fun um so that'll be uh on monday
and then i've got also on monday a
preview of endless dungeon yeah it's
gonna be coming out which is that one
it's a uh roguelite
tower defense type of game
for the makers of dungeon of the endless
and stuff like that
um yeah so that that one was pretty cool
and then uh
got some more previews coming up and
then my next review that i'm
working on is xenoblade chronicles 3
which
is
doesn't come out for a month so i've got
a lot of time to work on it but it's
going to take you about that monster
a monster of a game and for those of you
who don't know my history with the
xenoblade franchise i really like the
franchise but i do not like it enough
according to the xenoblade community oh
you flame me who flame me every time i
talk are you supposed to give it like
9.5 or something it's got to be a 10 out
of 10 or you're a heretic
i gave the xena blade chronicles one in
eight
that's an eight which is like
that's good for you yeah that's that
seems pretty solid and uh and they were
not have to be
they well i mean do they expect you just
to like disregard anything i mean
you seem generally fairly fair with your
reviews from what i've seen i mean if
you're gonna have a crap-tacular game
you're gonna give it a two or three it's
gonna be i don't know if you i don't do
you have a game that you would give a 10
i'm actually curious what that would be
because for you your standards
yeah like your standards would be pretty
high i think
i've certainly never reviewed a game
that was a 10 like if you let me review
my favorite games like if i reviewed
eldon ring maybe that would be a 10 you
know
that's like a masterpiece little game
but i don't really know i've never been
put in that position so it's really hard
for me to say i can't say that of all
the games i've reviewed which include
hundreds of games and not just for ign
like previously and i have reviewed some
like really high profile games in the
past i've never given a a 10 or
the equivalent of a 10 at any other
outlets i mean i do appreciate ign's
distinction where it's like it's a
masterpiece they never say perfect which
is fair like nothing's going to be
perfect but i mean solid they just want
it to be like 9.5 just very
exactly yeah and and ign doesn't do uh
yeah decimals so it's either yeah that's
right um
we used to but i actually think that
that world slayer uh you did a couple
questions about world slayer uh so
outriders world slayer comes out the
30th
technically it comes out on the 28th oh
yeah if you pre-order it have the the
pre-order version you can get early
access yep um that's important to note
because it's sort of a tricky thing that
uh developers publishers do where they
say the game's
out one day but they actually sell it to
you earlier and yada yada so the review
is available on the 27th before the game
officially goes out so you should read
it then if you're one of the people who
was planning on playing on the 28th just
in case you read my review and go wow i
absolutely don't want to do this um
so yeah
[Music]
but yeah xenoblade chronicles man i love
the franchise but i got absolutely
flamed uh with my last review so
hopefully this will go better but if it
doesn't i don't really care that's
that's my philosophy you're allowed
literally a review is one person's
opinion that's good yeah that's like
look at multiple people
yeah that's what you were saying e like
i do like to think that i'm fair um i
think that
the jrpg genre there's certain things
that
if you're a fan of jrpgs people assume
that you are able to just like
hand wave certain problems right
if there's a certain thing that jrpgs do
that's annoying and you point out that
that's annoying people will say oh well
that's part of the genre and i i do not
i do not give them a pass on that stuff
right like in persona 5 the fact that
you have to go to a save point to save
the game and you can't save at any time
some people go oh well that's like
classic jrpg and i go well it's stupid a
classic jrpg mechanic can also be dumb
right and so i like me with ld ring yeah
and so there's stuff like that it's
just because it's part of the genre
doesn't mean it is it is free from
critical i'm so
excited
yeah and so uh i i pointed at things i
think in the original my original
xenoblade chronicles review where people
were like wow this guy just doesn't get
it right because he he points out things
that are part of the genre we love but
sorry man i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
support a bad game design somebody
one person's got a review breath of the
wild is a nine right as opposed to
everybody who gave it a ten
or a six there's probably some nines out
there there's probably like the six out
there and that person just got do you
think so worth a while i don't know
there's probably one person just to like
mess with everybody
you never know but what about you what
are you been up to no besides not
feeling well trying to fight some stuff
but um a lot a lot what's been going on
oh duke obviously been been killing it
with that me and maddie been in pocket
with a lot of stuff we got a japanese
kind of like a
jrpg focus of um what microsoft's been
doing on that front
um guy that's up on ultimate that's
something that was a good episode we did
do go yesterday maddie has some
interesting bathroom habits there's a
big debate about that go check that out
oh i finally listened to that i know
exactly what you're talking about oh god
yeah it's it's we have we've now hitting
another challenge like i understood what
he said
me too like physically i understood what
he said
when i also went okay i'll break it down
but i'll well i'm not gonna go through
all the detail you gotta go listen to it
for that one but it was like yeah
bathroom medicine it's his like bathroom
habits and it was just the way just his
like process of using the facilities was
something i don't think i've heard and
or thought of doing and i'm just very i
was like very confused trying to see one
of those guys who fully takes off his
pants and sits on the toilet backwards
i've never heard that do you know about
this i've heard of that one i feel like
i've heard
but it requires you to fully take off
your pants and underwear which seem
really yes
the surrounding that has to be home city
yeah that has to be home oh yeah no way
you're doing that
that's where i came into question with
certain things with other people but
anyway so go check that out it's a fun
one um
yes for yeah as far as games um
started up uh ninja turtles we're
probably gonna do a stream with the
lords on saturday the sixth player
classic okay you know retro
what's
uh ninja turtles listening to different
people's like thoughts on that one i
know you're a huge streets of rage four
guys that one like hit like hit you in
the fields was like really good i mean
you enjoyed that one how does this hold
up in comparison
um
you got to be to be honest
all right i'm going to take my body i
feel like travis's thing we're like hey
it's just to beat them up so we're going
to give it you know all these little
experiences
look it's an antiquated formula we know
that this is you this is the spiritual
successor for one of the greatest
beat-em-ups of all time which is turtles
in time in the arcade right so if you
look at it from that lens yes it's doing
what it's doing but if you're looking at
a modern lens like this is the most
simple
you know
that that sounds about what i heard then
yeah yeah i mean i heard the pixel art
and the styling was really cool
soundtrack and jams but it was like
functionality people were people were
just saying like it needs it's still
yeah so what you said about old school
yeah it's all this is old school this is
a time piece that they gave a little
they gave a lot of love to and nostalgia
up the wazoo for everyone who wanted
this game because what it is they've
butchered turtle games after time like a
lot of turtle games were not good and
people like if you just do this and then
slightly modernize it you'll be good and
that's what it is so i've been doing
that i played a little bit of on by the
way that game is awesome yeah it's so
much fun so much fun naraka bladepoint i
was in that um beta for them kind of
like it's interesting the battle royal
but melee kind of i've seen it kind of
like i saw a couple people do streams
and stuff it's been yeah beta or not
quite final released for a while now a
lot of traversal absolutely fun and yet
i i think they got something a lot of
potential there i want to play a little
bit more um and the last one is i've
been playing demio crazy bro like demio
is just look vr
bro it is like i know you just care
because you're admitted of course you're
gonna say of course bro i'm telling you
right now i'm i'm very particular with
my turn-based turn-based one of my
favorite genres and prior to demio i
would say as far as the new on the scene
turn base i'll probably say phoenix
point and probably gears tactics with
two of them like as far as new entries
in the john xcom is like the goat for me
right and shout out to bike being he was
talking next car so much fun he's
terminates got to but
demeo for a new entry
and what they are doing and some of the
best mechanics i've ever seen in a boss
dungeon encounter like they got it and
they keep updating the game they keep
bringing classes so i did that and last
but not least of course destiny which i
had to hurry up and do before the show
because the servers
the servers kept kicking me out a day
ago yeah i was like why can't i do a
single player severe mission you know
what i knew something was wrong trav
if you start the mission now you go up
the hill in the beginning start and then
like the cabal shooting i'm like yo this
gumball won't die
like he kept yelling
his energy kept coming back like kill
him
right there yeah
that's what happens when i when you're
playing from a hotel room like if you're
playing on a hotel room super strict
gnat then you get that effect and you're
like damn it trap i've never experienced
that bro i never knew what it is to play
destiny with a bad connection i've never
done it i've played on a plane and you
get oh this is brutal you and your plain
wi-fi cracked me up
teddy teddy was like we were hanging out
with teddy like after you left he was
like oh yeah you can see gets it
everywhere like wi-fi right on the plane
i was just like i've never even thought
about doing wi-fi on the plane i
literally download a movie to an ipad
and watch that and i never even think
about doing the airplane wi-fi you got
to multitask man five hours i'm not
going to waste that that's i could be
making money during that time oh dude
coverage about this stuff going yeah
we'll talk about that but yeah i got a
playing fall guys
yes i played that i played that with dj
bill still watch out for bill stillwell
epic games now he's with epic
pop no pope couldn't make it so it was
me bill
dj all right
i spent so much time with that guy
online
like
this is pure pure savagery in its finest
like this game
it feels like it's played
like a year ago when we got to play it
so oh my god it's hilarious yeah the
last day oh
they're coming to
you're coming to the switch is a
blessing i think that's why
the resurgence it's just so much easier
to play when you don't have to
boot up the pc or
playstation yeah no i mean it was a
crazy fun game just stupid goofy antics
and i never played enough to really
practice on the games to kind of figure
out the nuances of being good i think i
got one crown but it's a hell of a fun
time if you got a couple people in a
party chat i'm sure it's just just pure
goofy
pure goofiness yeah so that's pretty
much been it for me as far as playing a
different variety of games and just you
know getting ready low slowly
here's another question have you guys
been watching any tv because even my
wife and i have been
going through like shows we've got one
that literally came out yesterday you
got umbrella academy that just started
up season three i literally just
finished stranger things season four
part one which is
very very good that show keeps
surprising me
like i got it it got all the budget it
ever wanted this season you can tell um
i even saw the reason they did the two
parts is i think the last episode is so
much vfx they just didn't quite get it
finished in time but not like and then
obi-wan there's two episodes left on
here those are the ones that are
actually worth watching because it has
been a bit slow to start i will
definitely say it's been i need travis
or not slower i'm ki i was like i
haven't watched the last two but
i've heard positive things about the
last two so i've kind of watched once
like five and six i haven't watched five
and six which are the main
ep
episodes for ob1 yeah those are the best
yeah those are the best ones that's what
i've heard so it's like going into it i
think it's a slow build
yeah i mean for i think the ign review
was an eight which is great i would i
wouldn't go that far i'd say maybe it's
a seven maybe a six if i'm having a bad
day is definitely hogue has some
opinions
okay here's the whole here's the thing
here's the thing
is wrong and
he's
he is so down on the series as a whole i
don't think that you i don't think
there's anything that star wars could do
that would make him happy unless it was
literally just an hour-long reel of luke
skywalker killing things with the
lightsaber like that's what it would
have to be like whole game
dude he's just an old curmudgeon and
anytime they do anything new in the
series he's just like
he's trash and i'm like dude
you're clearly not a star wars fan you
haven't liked star wars since 1983 so i
think it's time to hang up your hat
and he's one of those people he said he
said that
he said the prequels looked oscar worthy
compared to the obi-wan show
oh that's this come on
come on
that's like so hyperbolic that i no
longer i no longer want to listen to
anything you have to say because it's
just come on that's like shout out the
whole glow no and so yeah i i think i
think it's middling as a show i think
yeah it has some really great moments
and has some moments that aren't that
good it has some cinematography problems
but uh it is
um quality star wars if you're star wars
fan you're probably gonna like a lot of
it and uh
i keep saying this but we're never gonna
have worse star wars than attack of the
clones we're never gonna have better
star wars than empire strikes back so
let's just be happy living in the middle
eternally that's where we're gonna be
right going forward it's all just gonna
be in between those two so let's just
let's just live there
and that's honestly what i've been here
and i saw like a brief like snippets and
tried not to read too much but like the
last couple episodes five and six i
heard were
very solid let me shout out my man
gaming forte
because i put this man through something
this week with dusty oh no hey i owe him
with apology he's a friend let me tell
you i gave him a fourteen friend because
i know that
that's the hobby right i i tried i
didn't do trials you know and then like
sinister gets on and i don't like
playing with sinister i don't teddy i
love you i don't like playing with you
either the problem is first of all teddy
you know he with his pc and then the
master race people come in and they they
terrorize us right so it's never fun for
me right so then i don't like playing
with sinister because he's already gone
flawless by friday so if i play with him
on screen in his pool it's over for me
then i'm seeing the most
esportsy things i've never seen before
and it's not it's not fun for me
for it so i'm like yo all i need to get
is rank 10. i just want the burden to
guilt what is it the kinetic fusion from
trials that's all i want right so i'm
like i'm so close and i'm like i can't
win a match so like i we literally
challenge you we bully before into this
be like please bro can you just come on
because you're not in the flawless pool
you're the only person at all right now
he's like all right all right and he
helped me get it so i got i got my
fusion i'm happy i owe that man shout
out to gaming forte for holding me down
and do it because he don't even play
trousers he's just like i am not doing
this trying like he he's like done until
they make major change he's in the
travis but he's like i'm not doing this
but he did it out of friendship so
salute the game before too shout out to
shout out to that for sure while we're
doing shout outs shout out to teddy for
i finally i i took a page from my jewish
grandma's book and guilt tripped him
into uh into doing the vox uh oh
yeah box obscure masks
yeah yeah we did a master got the
by the way
messenger
super underrated thank you that's a fun
weapon oh my god it's pretty good yeah
and that that radius with the three and
then
the ground just stay with the ground
yeah it's it's great i love wave frames
and and it's basically the hard light of
wave frames with a better radius like
it's really good i idea the catalyst
makes it even better so um yeah
so shout out to teddy thanks for doing
that man
you're still uh you're still
insufferable to play with but i love you
okay
hello but is he is he is he's difficult
isn't he he's like the type of guy who
will like look at your loadout and tell
you exactly what to equip
he's so good he always helps out though
i love him but he's toxic i'm forwarding
shout outs right now i'm going to shout
out to people who are going to be on the
show in the future because i've been
dming a lot of people i'm not saying who
yet because i gotta do the announcement
later
but i was like i'm just like deeming
people on twitter and just
so far everybody's been great and i'm
just like i wanna shout out to again
awesome community yes got a chance to
meet some of them gcx but it was like
maybe a handshake a photo and a hello
one time later and then all of a sudden
you know talk them into a podcast so
well just awesome people in the
community you guys will see who it is
but yeah i was like
it's been fun i know i haven't been
streaming that much lately just
between the dog and trying to eat a
little healthier and get workouts in and
everything else i know i haven't been
but i definitely want two more so those
of you guys are waiting on me streaming
it'll get there just give me time no
doubt no doubt life comes first bruh yep
well
there's this thing called destiny we
have been playing a little bit hey
what's going on with this game uh the
biggest thing this week uh
sever rage we got to actually get to see
what was going on with kaidel so
the freshest man in the room who
probably got done playing it before he
took his little break before the show
started
how you feeling on it sir how's how's
the title this adventure
um
okay
uh maybe my expectation for what i was
expecting from kyle was too high
um i like gold i like gauls um
the way he was i got you would say
tormenting you know her i thought was
interesting i liked you know the fact
that you know he basically you know was
calling her out on certain things as far
as her association with the traveler and
lightbearers and things like that i like
that little dynamic there
i guess
i think i've struggled with kaido
because like she didn't want to do
she first of all she doesn't listen
right so she's like i'm not doing your
stupid hive witch ritual
i'm going there to fight in the the
tradition of of of cabal and face by
nightmare head-on clearly we know she's
not going to win and it's like hi eric's
like please go get her like this is not
going to work whatever she's doing right
so we get there um
the fight itself was was decent to me it
was like on red wall when you fought
yeah it was like when you read war when
you fought gaul but in a very confined
space yeah you know kind of thing and
they had you do a couple of steps
beforehand you know i guess like i said
the only issue i'm having with the seven
missions and e help me out with this
i feel the resolutions are too fast
i said that last week yeah i feel like
it's like okay
i'm struggling okay i can't do it
eris okay
and next week i have the resolve i
understand my thing and i have reached
enlightenment every every other week
come on you can't have this level of
like the torment i feel is legit but the
resolutions i feel are just too fat and
that's what's suspending this belief
just to advance the story as far as i'm
concerned but i mean as far as that like
i said the missions are standing fair it
is what it is but um i want to see i
want to see you know how they resolve
and then obviously i did like the last
part
with the with the pyramid and then
you're finding out more about um he you
know literally kallus is
doing this to commune with the witness
so we got to witness tie-in that i know
um travis has been wanting kind of thing
but yeah that that's where i'm at with
it i'm curious you know what you guys
thought about it because i literally
just did it
yeah
um my thoughts are i'm kind of on the
same boat as you i'm a little
underwhelmed by the story this season
and i know i know this this game is
getting a lot of praise at the moment
for its narrative and definitely the
narrative is the thing that's carrying
the season because everything else in my
opinion is not great
but uh
i still feel like
destiny sometimes gets a little too much
credit for the stuff it does in that
story like
this the story this season is
good for destiny like that's the
asterisk right like it's like there's
actual character development stuff going
on but it's not
you know revolutionary in in the games
industry or compared to other games that
have ongoing stories and stuff like that
it's not anything special i would say
what's happening uh this season i like
the themes around it i like the
you know thoughts of dealing with trauma
and
accepting yourself and your past and
yada yada all that stuff's really cool
but yeah to your point cog like the
pacing is a little off the actual
activities we're doing to resolve it
feel weird it's like oh yeah place the
resonators and then
kill some guys
kill some guys well you know they talk
they have a therapy session with their
their own nightmares and it's just like
all of it is a little
you know
it's like a a nice topping on a
not-so-great dessert like it it it it
just
doesn't feel like super complete so
um i'm sort of with you cog i i i'm very
much over it the only thing i would say
to your point of it being too quick
which generally i agree with but
do you really want to do more
because for me like yeah for me it's
like they kind of need to just wrap it
up because i don't know how much longer
people would log on and do this damn
activity where we're walking around a
place we've already been before it's the
same
damage some people are really enjoying
the run back to the leviathan i didn't
do something
good for those people i am not one of
them uh
and so uh yeah i i kind of think that
that they they almost have to have to
wrap this thing up and i'm uh we'll see
i'll see what the resolution's like i'm
interested
it to see if the witness connection is
enough because right now my feeling is i
get that the witness is involved but the
witnesses involved in the same way that
the darkness was involved in past
destiny which is that
the darkness is involved only in name
you know it's like references like oh
this is happening because of the
darkness and it's like all right well
what does that actually mean like is
there some plan here or am i just
fighting a mini boss while i wait for
the actual meaty content to get here um
so for me the witness connection is nice
but i don't i'm not seeing it as being
enough of a connection for me to really
matter it's not advancing the overall
plot of destiny it's it's just spinning
our wheels while we do some distraction
that is
related to the witness and the darkness
but not really not really related so
just not not a lot of character not a
lot of story progression even though the
character progression is cool you know
zavala's progression doesn't really move
the needle it's sort of shallow it's
just hey this character you never knew
about he had problems with her and now
they're resolved and uh hey this i mean
there's a little more to it than that
but
yeah i mean but the
the dead character of gaul had some
problems with kaidel and now that's
being resolved and really the only one i
think has like
possible real
consequences is the crow now kind of
being back on the the okay train yeah it
was a little touch and go there for a
moment but yeah i could ramble on about
the story and destiny forever but i'm
i'm not a huge fan of
the season really in any regard right
now enough for you before i give it to e
i know you're gonna talk um i did want
to mention there is one thing i do like
and it has nothing to do with the
narrative it's always in the seventh
mission and i want them to expire the
part a little bit more
the fun part with there's this
invincible nightmare galron running
around chasing you i think that was
funny i don't know why like he's really
he can't really kill you kill you
because obviously you rest back this
weekend kill him for a chance yes and i
was like i was nice i was like come on
down here todd are you chasing me around
down the hallway
i said come into this fight come into
the i like that but i just wanted to
shout that part out but e where are you
at man where you at with the story this
week
i mean that was kind of one of the
things like week three was really well
told i thought because i mean i know
travis said it's a character we didn't
know about but it was a way to
it gave some
reasoning as to why zavala has been the
way he is kind of like a stick of his
ass vanguard guide not really wanting to
do too much not want the venture out too
far
trying to almost like follow the book to
a fault that kind of guy and we got a
little bit of like behind the scenes
look as to
how we got there
i actually really enjoyed that and that
was when i said before we had tom on
last week
uh the week before that i said like
zavala's felt like a kind of wrapped
smooth like
but again also as travis said how many
weeks do you want to repeat this and i
think this is the balance of
i mean in risen
very tight story four weeks long one two
three four crow messed up but you know
forge valas forge now exists because of
that and he's a badass in the cabal
ranks and we got that you know
resolution because of it it was a tight
little story this is sick this is going
to be seven there's seven weeks at least
to whatever the lore book or something
is so whatever the seventh week is seems
like it's going to be the thing and i
think that's the point where it'll be
like kind of where i decided when you
guys were saying
obi-wan five and six kind of make it get
the grade that it even has a chance of
getting because of those two episodes
are so strong
um i'm very curious how this one
resolves because as travis is saying if
it doesn't push the arc forward
it is going to be
these are like the flashback episodes in
the middle of a syndicated tv show in
which you like it's cool to learn about
stuff about the characters but you don't
move like the general arc forward which
is kind of what we're going for into the
seasons so if seven can take you know
one two three four five and six and the
pairs of those and take seven and go
alright now we got all this stuff and
we're going into like you know the next
season going towards the witness the
witnessing you know if callus and the
witness have some weird discussion that
we hear about or we get something along
you know the building of him into being
another disciple or something that would
be cool that's what i'm hoping for in
seven hopefully we get to see it in some
way
maybe something goes wrong maybe
everything goes smoothly and we sever
his connection and he has to go i don't
know but like
i need seven to deliver
so i know we're two weeks away from that
sorry yeah
so i need that's kind of where i'm at
i'm enjoying getting the history
like hearing
hearing gaul talk to kaidel kind of
gives an idea of you know what she went
through and she was more learned to use
taught to use her brain and calls like
you should be a warrior what the hell
are you doing working with these so i
mean it's cool to see them kind of play
off each other a little bit in each one
of them
but it it does feel weird when they go
through so much crap in the first week
that they're a thing and the second week
it's like i don't need you and then okay
now we're going to shake hands and it's
like but as but how much longer do you
need it to be
so it's kind of that thing it's like i
mean if you got three characters you
want to tell a story you gotta you know
issue resolution three times and then
hopefully seven is the delivery so
that's kind of where i'm at is seven
needs to deliver otherwise it's gonna be
cool to know the history but
you know kind of may not hit if seven
doesn't so that's where i'm at on it i
wanna see what it where it ends
no i feel you i think um
for me also while i guess this one
i felt like mix is because i've actually
liked the goal character and i always
felt the the the voice by the way
so good golf should have been the bad
guy for the full first year of destiny
yes at least he he got axed way too
quickly and and i loved that that whole
story with him so
yeah you know it's like damn just when
you get a little bit you know i know
it's gonna go away again what'd you guys
say jeff yeah yeah i was just saying
they botched that story so badly that i
actually get indignant when they bring
him back like this especially when you
fight him and he goes super saiyan again
and i have to remember that boss how
that all ended
you had such a good character that whole
story was good up until the last mission
when you killed him
the red campaign was actually i don't
know if it gets enough credit because i
really enjoyed it it was so good i think
that that's probably the second best
story that they've told behind the witch
queen uh i i really like that campaign
yes i just think it ends terribly and
then the whole like the game of thrones
sour no sour taste in your mouth in the
end exactly it almost invalidates the
journey it makes you feel and then they
the fact that they don't use the fact
that the traveler woke up like that was
the whole point of him dying right is
like the traveler
awoken and then what does he do oh he
just
sits there for a couple years and then
during a live event he puts himself back
together and then
just chills and has done nothing and i'm
just like what
it's been a learning experience for
bungie to figure out what what they want
to do with this franchise i mean it's
been
obviously as you said like the red word
campaign then they kill him off the
traveler a couple years later worf as we
talked with tom last week it was
you know season 10 and season 13 season
seeing some of these seasons they're
finally figuring out okay there is
something we can do with all of this
stuff and it seems like it actually has
a plan to it somewhere on a whiteboard
all this stuff has been kind of
vaguely planned by the narrative team
which is good because yeah connections
they're getting those notes handed down
to them yeah
yeah yeah that's it but i mean overall
mission's kind of fun apparently there's
i will definitely say that when it comes
to like oh what's the seasonal challenge
this this week that you've got to do and
it's go run sever grief which is like
three
with a different subclass but you can't
touch the scythe because then that bugs
it out out because it can't explode or
it has to it can't be solar
so but it's also the fact that go play
mission just with another subclass and
i'm like yeah we
we can't get
i don't want to you know this is one of
those moments i was like i feel like we
need a little more creativity in the
challenges
than that there's i don't know what else
specifically in the world this season
that you know could be maybe a little
thin on that type of stuff but go do a
mission just with a different subclass
doesn't really feel the best when you
read that because i think that's what it
was a week or two back as well i'm just
like
yeah yeah i gotta i actually gotta do
that i gotta focus back on a couple of
the older ones what is it kinetic you
run it with a void and yeah one was like
kinetico something like that yeah i
haven't looked at all of them i probably
need to fragment thing so i can unlock
more stuff on my electrical because i
really want to start focusing i don't
have a good miter mini tool oh i got
mine crafted and i can't put it down
what you got what you got what you put
on i'll just put incandescent i don't
even know what the second perk is right
now just enhanced incandescent because i
actually was going doing the
nightmare containment i got an ascendant
alloy to drop i'm like oh i know exactly
what i'm using that for baby drop it in
containment yeah i haven't seen that
many but i did get one to drop and it
was actually went to my postmaster i was
like oh i'm crafting this right now so i
just went to go shoot a bunch of stuff
with my callous mini tool i got a drain
crafted i just like literally today i
think i got that crafted
is that still bugged does that still be
string
yeah
yeah well the drain specifically i said
it was telling me like there's something
i don't know if it still is or not i'm
more just like it's a fun sidearm to use
i like it yeah
absolutely and sidearms are awesome
right now mm-hmm yes they do and then
next week they're gonna get fixed
for uh pv for the barrier thing
wait hold on chad what side of you using
the pvp
trespasser
that one might have good synergy next
season that one might be good see that
could have been next season's exotic oh
traffic is gonna be late for awk 3.0
yeah um
i mean i'm using a few of them i can't
remember
i think i am using drang a little bit
that one's really good right now
actually i recently switched to
submachine guns because they're just so
delightful but yeah i was using
trespasser before that and now i'm using
my i got like a god rule of callus mini
tool and i'm just
sweeping up so yeah
or kalos minitool feels good so
i haven't had time to play in a while
though i'll be honest pvp specifically i
need to get back in there i think i'm
waiting for i'm waiting for iron banner
but i'm gonna yeah
i'm just gonna go oh god what weekend is
that it's next week next week right yeah
next week is july right you said it was
july 4th weekend or july 14th oh yeah
you got to look at uh
somebody in chat telling me shout out to
gaming so it would be the one chatting
because it's youtube and not twitch
what's up attic
when is iron banner because i have
family coming in town next weekend um
please tell me it's the fifth
yeah
okay then i'm good because if it's over
the fourth weekend and that's where i'm
banner is that's when the family's here
and then the fifth if it starts then i'm
then then i'm excellent 12. yeah the
fourth one doesn't sound right okay
banner really 12.
wow they're saying it's the 12th okay
you guys lied to me because you guys
said it was the first week of july and i
wrote that stuff down on my calendar a
couple episodes ago i got a look i
seriously got a look now because i
didn't think that was it
could be your own shout out the attic
super chat because youtube sounds too
long it's only happening twice this
season right so we only have one left
yeah
it's week eight i know that
oh my god he got his eye a little bit i
had to get that lord yeah no doubt we
might have to make that a requirement we
might have to make people to clan man
that might be the rule we already start
sifting through
you ain't got eye a little tight
yes pain
new rash says the 12th
really
all right well oh yeah our banner is
awful but it is technically pvp and so
i'm gonna
touch the riff hope to get that holder
yeah sure yeah that'll work timing
while you're in there well i haven't
gotten the catalyst to drop yet so yeah
i'm just having really bad luck but
that's the last catalyst i need to
finish so nice don't go
nice but i'll be caught up
nice
yeah well that works because yeah i got
my wife's family's coming in to visit
for that july 4th weekend so i don't
know what we're gonna do since it's
gonna be a thousand degrees but we'll
see but yeah i was like i was if they
were gonna be here for iron banner
weekend that was gonna be a long grind
of a couple days before they got here
a little more thank goodness
what else have you guys been doing have
you been doing any of the other dungeons
for pinnacles or anything like that have
you been in yeah
yeah oh you got did you get it
not yet
anybody got the um what is it the
kinetic uh
no no i don't even got that yeah i ain't
got that either i got a god roll
what you got
frenzy and
camera what the other perk was what yeah
absolutely
uh storm chaser
now that i know it's not craftable i've
been
uh
i've been looking as soon as you guys
said that i looked on my phone and i was
like all right let me see what roles
i've got because i guess now i'm not
gonna be able to craft and uh
it was a
harrowing moment in my life but yeah i i
i have a pretty good role so nice yes i
still need storm tracer i mean sometimes
i need them
i'm pretty sure stormchasers bugged
really
it does like 50 more damage than the
next highest it does a ton of damage
i mean it's a three burst
it's it's one of those i don't know if
it's like if you're
in that dungeon since you're standing
right next to two of the bosses
especially kyle she just you stun her
and she stands there like she's gonna be
the easiest target ever
if you try and use that on a farther
target i don't know how the triple tap
like recoil how it's gonna be i haven't
tested it that much i wonder how that
thing is to manage on
you know bosses with slightly small like
cali for example in last wish would
probably be impossible with the kicks
that's that's why i don't know if the
math
if if it met if it makes a difference or
not but yeah it's definitely got some
potency in the right place for sure yeah
it's uh it's the meta right now for pve
100 mm-hmm yeah yeah i like that
man i just want that lingering dress i
mean
after this [ __ ]
again
have you done it this week
i have not
did a reset so we can then yes again
this is destiny you got to do activities
50 times i owe you this time oh you're
this time that's how i'll ditch you for
dj
it's like i feel like somebody
definitely got called out
yeah and it was really serious so he
agreed to do the dungeon with me and
teddy on the show and then as soon as
the show was over he messaged me and
goes my clan mates are saying i should
be playing with them i got to stay loyal
sorry guys and you know what the messed
up part was teddy and i were just
hanging out waiting for him to log on oh
sorry
he messages us like two hours after it's
like dude we've just we've been sitting
here waiting for you
he literally lied we literally were we
were like
i swear to you we were waiting for you
to log on and we were like we're just
sitting there for two hours not doing it
where's cox stop it no we we knew you
were logging on later but like he said
he was gonna eat he's taking a while i
don't know
maybe he just eats a lot and then no it
turns out that's how you that's how you
become always ain't loyal
that's how you become
[Laughter]
i love how flawless even said that on
twitter it's like i still remember that
time he called me [ __ ] and he bonds just
meat boxes and i was like i'm not so
that was funny no if we walk around
together you guys look like centurions
and i'm a scion that's the we're the
cabal squad
right now
yeah we should do some cosplay i'd be a
good scion you're late
you're like
it'd be it'd be like gears of war if
because you use that reference it's like
he and i are shooting all the aliens and
we're trying to keep the little
scientist guy alive between us
that's exactly
shout out to necromancer zeal which one
of the three races would you like to see
in story content next season uh i want
more on the vex and the blue lines blue
lynn's harpy actually was kind of cool
the fact that he was like a kind of good
guy
uh who do you guys want to see because
obviously this season we know what's
kind of generally going to be going on
where do you guys think next season
might go
i know we're going to theoretically get
the raid whichever way they go with that
i don't know but where do you guys think
the story goes or what would you like to
see what do we do for i think it is time
for the facts right we've been it's been
we've been vexeless for a little bit the
problem with the facts just they like
the
they're the hive mind
they almost need to be controlled by
like another entity that we could then
when you need to
missed opportunity
could have been sweet
he could have had a personality they
could have made it a thing but they
decided to just kill him in a subpar
boss fight yep
that's that's bungie's move they kill
all the best characters in lackluster
boss fights
they've been doing that since halo
that's their whole mo um so
i uh yeah i i agree i don't want to see
the vex until they figure out what
they're doing with it so tk omar chat
said
[Music]
make rasputin take over a faction of the
vex and use their bodies to be our
allies
fire
that rasputin gets sentient
and yeah he has some connection with the
thing he uses the cfm to take over yeah
the vex take over a faction of the vex
and then we can have some of them in the
tower and that'll completely
complete the prophecy there you go uh
do that do something interesting but if
you're not going to do that then my
choice is
hive because i want you to start using
your hive guardians because i'm obsessed
with
you
you want that elusive brew back already
i never go back i i was the last time
you killed a hive guardian when's the
last time you crushed a ghost i did a
lot i did literally a lost sector on the
throne world and i was like oh yeah
i did it yesterday it was yesterday i
did the video before
extraction i don't do strikes or
anything so like it's been
since which queen like i haven't i
haven't crushed a ghost like even if you
do strikes odds are against
statistically so
and oh speaking of which i got a fun
thing for y'all um how many of you if
the ad kings fall they should throw in i
have guardians i've got it oh
that greatest rate of all-time valve
disciple how many times you i don't hear
anybody talking about that
i just haven't been raiding period
oh i haven't been reading it never said
it was my favorite but i uh
i got i got the scout rifle and was like
die bye
prisoner of the moment that raid after
the
people gonna get tired of chicken
fingers and and witnesses
bother me i just haven't raided much at
all
it's not
it's the greatest raid of all right
to be i gotta start cog i feel the exact
same way about the last word last wish i
never did that right after i got the
fusion rifle and i've i've i've gone
back
just to do shiro chi that's it so
that's hard that's that's very
disrespectful wow
last wish
this is my most disrespectful face i'm
giving unless this is
[Laughter]
i ran wrath of the machines for fun so
which i would rather i could go for a
siege engine right now
sam what do you want to choose yeah
if you got the pick you're up there at
the luke smith board and you're like
make
i choose king's fall but only because i
think they could modernize it and make
it cool with uh hive guardians and stuff
and i i don't want to
i don't think they can do it with the
fallen first of all the spicers aren't
even really in
oh yeah that's right the splicer didn't
even really know i don't know how they
do it that's a good point now i mean got
to get kicks fall for you guys you know
i want to i want to really
revisit it with the d2 flavor right
right this is the beginning i just said
the jumping puzzle i forgot about oh god
not the penis wall oh god no not that
one the ship jumping puzzle oh that's
the one that's terrorized
you guys ever see a wall and you kind of
go
get a little hot into the color there
huh okay well you were going to be here
it's a wall
there's quite a wall yeah
okay rat is the more fun for me but i
have to admit like
damn that [ __ ] puzzle used to yo i used
to get clowned how bad i used to mess
that up they they would all five of them
just sit there and laugh at me because i
couldn't get to the other side fast it
would be that one joke we had to kind of
like reverse thing and it's that jump
towards the end of the the ship jumping
puzzle i used to butcher that thing
other than that like um
what's his name goggle rob look is it go
girl this is that yeah
that's a big ogre and
sisters
you gotta see orex you gotta see oryx
just to see him you gotta see him you're
saying like
you gotta see it i i will i would love
to see how it holds up and it's gonna be
too much i'm sure we could be too much
if they changed the name to queen's fall
made it
a sabbath giant sabbath dune at the end
and redid the final encounter so that
it's less bad would that be too much
why is it to that level i don't think
that that's that's where you're just
going to get into the bait datto head is
like video over the three of these like
he was like what would we do to bring
back their aids and the idea is
they tend to want to keep the encounters
close to what they were before
to keep the feeling of the raid the same
so if you
change up the mechanics of an encounter
too much it's not the same raid we went
through i'm not saying i wouldn't mind
some tweaks to things but i feel like
you might not get much more than tweak
as opposed to
reworking an encounter completely like
if they got rid of the bombs that you
stand in people would be like well this
isn't like the raid that i knew and then
you're gonna get that session of people
being annoyed
yeah i mean they're gonna have to rework
it no matter what
because
some of those encounters don't really
work like we're way faster so i feel
like the jumping puzzle
during the king's fall boss fight
doesn't really make sense anymore you
know
oh the one up in the air
yeah there's plenty of people who would
uh mess that one up i would imagine
you think so i think they'd overshoot it
because before you were like barely
making it i feel like we are too quick
now i don't know man i have
i don't know if i even like the idea of
them bringing back the old raids really
yeah
wow
different sandboxes they weren't made
for it it's a lot of time and effort to
put in when you could just be making a
new raid i don't know man the assets are
there though i don't know
you could use the assets for new raid
you know what it means
you don't have to create new assets
you don't have to recreate exactly what
you did i mean it's not like the destiny
if the destiny 1 servers were offline i
would say yeah for sure we need them but
we need 60 frames i am not shout out to
them like destiny one sorry baby try
pc them
true they could do that but i was like
they'd be like let's do kig's fault i'm
like not at 30 frames i'm waiting for it
to come back
you can also you could also just do an
update for d1 that brings it to 60
frames that would be super easy to do i
am not touching it i was like i think
they respectfully disagree that it's
easy otherwise they probably would have
but
no it's probably this thing it's not
worth the effort but i mean like some
some games already
do that automatically
that aren't dependent on servers because
of the uh the up res honestly
yeah
i i don't think that it's there's no way
that's going to be incredible but anyway
anyway i digress mm-hmm
what else he
yeah i was like no it's yeah i don't
know if
i don't know i mean i feel like king's
fall would be
the one that thematically goes with the
hive of this year but i think it just
would be really cool to see siva like
just as something so juxtaposed from
everything we have going on right now
and again it would be cool to see them
if they did a rasputin story if they did
a respectable story in king's fall i'd
be like what the hell are you doing
like that's the point where i'd have to
ask you pick the wrong one even if i
like king's falls you know from a d1
perspective
didn't they do that with vaulted glass
though
vault of glass came out with what
i mean vault of glass was the first one
they were doing i know but i don't even
know what was going on wasn't it nothing
related i mean it's not related and
that's the thing is i know it probably
it would just be like if the relation
could be there and then they still did
the different one that's what i mean
it's like i don't expect there to be any
tie-in to it so i expect like siva to
come out during like a cabal season or
whatever but if it was actually hey
we're doing stuff with caesar steven or
sputen and then you're like and here's
king's fall i'm like yeah that doesn't
feel quite right that's all i mean is
like
if that was the time to choose then that
would be my choice i still want to hear
from sabathan's ghost so
yeah if they send it back to king's fall
make it a thing where like he has gone
to
uh oryx's throne world and adds some
dialogue from him in there because i
feel like you need story you need some
sort of explanation so like
make it like a quest where you there's a
reason you have to go back there or
something
that's all i'm saying i would love it
too they just seem like did they put out
a statement like they're not gonna tie
them yeah oh they're not i know they're
not i mean and that's why but it would
just be
it would be very funny because it's like
okay so the next thing in the story we
need to do is analog
into that into an engram and then all of
a sudden yeah it's it's like you guys
know they're not gonna put story in
why do you want the raisin d2 do you
want the raids in d2 because it's
content
that we had
that we paid for
technically you know
so you're you're talking
you're talking bungie into doing more of
what this season is which is like
bringing back an old location and
putting it back in the game because it's
old content you had and you want it yeah
yeah because due to the reason
i love it here's the day because
you love it you love it
raids raids raids are the best content
in destiny and i feel more people should
play them and i think it sucks when it
goes away and there's no la full of
way you can play d1
i'm not playing
going back to that
that dirty friend you had me go back to
the hood 30 frames we live in nice now
we moved out of that area
we don't live in that neighborhood no
more travis we we doing this we got cops
and you see what we doing like we live
in the opulent life
are you having me go down there 30
frames isn't that bad first of all
have you ever played a switch game
you're like all at 30 frames it's not
that big of a deal second of all destiny
is metroid wasn't
destiny isn't a highly responsive
shooter that requires 60 frames it's
like a casual shooter you could play it
at 30 frames and be fine in fact
no one going back to that you go you you
could choose to go back yeah you have
fun at day one you have fun i'm gonna be
over here with the 4k to hdr i know god
bless god
bless we not doing that we living nice
we falutin over here
we got the pinky ring up everything's
nice it's cool that's what we want to do
now who's pretentious oh i'm very
pretentious
oh absolutely nice new engine better
servers then you talk about the old
systems where we doing the spin metal
with the circle oh no oh
busted and new hotness no hardness we're
going with new hotness this stuff in the
old system was better though
you go ahead you die you tell me how it
works do the ign review for that d1 20
years
how old are you
he perceives
you know what i would rather play in d1
than d2 talk to me
trials
charles was better
charles is better i'd give you that
charles there's a lot in that game that
was better
i'm just saying i
would you would rather i think we can
agree you would rather than work on new
raids than remastered of course of
course of course
all things of course always knew content
before the only thing is i just hate
because i look at
maddie's my test case
maddie was like damn i see y'all i want
to play destiny
but morally he's like it is wrong
that they have taken content away
right so it's hard
like when we talk about red wall
campaign you know what i'm saying we
talk about leviathan that was that was
part of the red war that was there and
the fact that i can't show him that he
like let me know and hog is out too
hogue said after the dcv hug folded he
came back down
oh he's back yeah he played when he
played the witch queen after all that
noise he went really
fraud alert
so that's number one two i would love to
debate maddie on removing content from
games because
this has been a practice that's been in
games for much longer than destiny and
it's not even really unusual at this
point it's kind of just the model for
live service so i think people who
no offense are older and have an older
view of games and the way that they
think games should be
they have a problem with live services
games model and i'm just like they're
just different models man
you sign up for a live service you
understand that things are going to
change and they're they're live servers
and
there's there's plenty of other games
that do it does warframe remove content
i don't know i'm asking
no uh
craft and warframe don't but they also
don't have the same problem uh i mean
world remasters stuff though i mean
they'll do yeah they're reworking their
warcraft remastered stuff they do
destroy certain areas and versions of
the game that you can't go back to and
items and like something that nobody
ever talks about is
after a multiplayer game has been around
for a while they turn off the servers
and you can't play it
that is technically taking away content
you paid for but like
what's the alternative right keep the
servers running when nobody's on it like
just that's the reality of the situation
i think the issue is for people who
that we're trying to get in the destiny
that like we always complain about the
new light system right and all they want
to do is say okay i'll get down but and
they're willing to go back to do red
wall forsaken they want to do it in this
chronological order and when i tell them
oh no that's not there but you could
start here and you could do beyond light
and they like but i want to know what
happened before i don't know anything
that's the tough sell and that's why i
said maddie's by example and i'm like
that's why i wish there was some way
they even if it's like you log into the
old d1 server up rest and you could just
do that and it doesn't even affect
anything and then you're up to speed to
what the live service game is i don't
know how you solve that issue i i i
understand your point just as if there
was like service don't work like that
and you're absolutely right it's just
that i i want to win over that guy and i
don't know how to win that guy over
there give him an offline server to play
on make an offline version of this yeah
make optional do you want to download
the red campaign and play it and then
you can choose like here's the required
things to play the current piece of the
game
and then if they could re-raster red war
forsaken and those types of things it's
like and you could like lock in destiny
and just like you want to do current or
like archive and you can go play that
archive of you know at least the
campaign the stories and that could be
an optional download however big the
damn file size is let people download it
and experience it because i do agree
that the new light experiences you can
go to the timeline right now but you're
not going to see
you're not going to see i mean minus the
final gall mission you're not going to
see the speaker actually have what
happens to him you're not going to see
the opening mission with aikora and
zavala
you know hold it down and then i-core
have her iconic moment of just blowing
up the ship with her nova bomb and then
anova bomb two seconds later where she
has no recharge time like
you won't get those moments so those are
ones i wish they could do something like
a final fantasy it's like hey go play
through all the old stuff even if it's
free we don't care
then you want people to start logging in
doing microtransactions go to your
eververse store
people would have a chance to do that
exactly now granted they have the issue
of
they may not love those campaigns they
may not be as proud of them because of
what the game was going through but
that's still i mean i'm sure
what is it a realm reborn for final
fantasy is not their favorite piece of
content versus
where they just did within walker but
you still got to go through the journey
yeah i think they're sad that
i'm listening to what you talk and it's
like some people don't even know who the
speaker is exactly
some people don't even know who kade is
think about there's people that play
destiny right now they're still happy
you know i'd but i mean you're right
let's strike his voice is the argument
for like doing the d1 model though right
because none of the d1 content got taken
away from you well the game only lasted
three years
that's the difference they want they
didn't want to put a two on the box they
would have probably kept it there if
they could want to well final fantasy
has been going on for what eight years
final fantasy 14. they haven't taken out
old campaigns
so
i i i
sort of have never really believed the
reason but i remember i was on fire team
chat when they announced the destiny
content vault
we were talking about about it that week
and i thought
oh this is going to be like a separate
app that you can go to to play all the
old content that isn't a part of the
live game that was like my initial
thought
and i don't think that
taking content out of a game is morally
wrong like matt i think it's actually
you have to do it at some point if
depending on you know you're the creator
of your game like if you if you fortnite
doesn't keep all their live events that
you can go and replay them right like
that's just not really the model um but
i do think it's a shame from a game
preservation perspective that there's no
way to go back and do it and that's
where
that's the thing that came out and
that's maddie's whole thing his whole
life
preservation hurts me bro that's his
that you should spoke to his soul that's
literally what that kid's whole thing is
he's all about game preservation he's
the guy that has used games he wants to
be able to he's that guy so yeah he's
got a little retro rebound is it a whole
channel yeah right yeah yeah whole whole
chat whole chat show yeah
yeah i mean that's i think
i am very intrigued for lightfall
because i know that's going to be
another huge moment i'm very excited for
arc 3.0 next season i'm very excited for
the dungeon in season 19. i'm very
excited for
possible rework of survival slash
competitive maybe in season 19 cross
your fingers and hope we get some pvp
love there like
those are the big moments in the
franchise that i'm looking forward to
the weekly login for the journey playing
with some friends here solo soloing this
content having a raid moment those are
going to happen along the way
but it does feel like we are going to
have some light moments in between and
again like the stories they tell
so far have been good and it's like and
all it is it's about pacing like i we
when i finished stranger things we
finished episode seven last night of
part one
and even my wife was saying
there's a piece of the story she's like
i'm kind of over this piece of this
story and then they brought that stuff
full circle in the perfect way and
you're like
damn it like they and that was like and
that was really well done when they
brought it around and that's the type of
stuff when you get those moments you're
like okay it was worth it cool
um and those are the ones that i just
hope we keep getting in this because
we've had some good ones i just want
them to keep going it just does feel
like
it's taking a little while to get to
some of them
and then some of the filler feels like
more filler than others that's part of
it
yeah i think it's just the nature of the
live service i think part of it is they
have to put us on hold for a little bit
just because of you know just the way
the seasonal structure is you know and
um the over like what tom said like
there's that overall arcing timeline of
what's supposed to happen with the big
team and the expansions and then they
got to work in this constrained box and
not to go too far here not use this
character here
and that's that's the thing of it so i
understand it but yeah i don't mean
same question since we're talking about
the future of destiny
let's go according to bungie
lightfall's coming out in
spring of 2023.
theoretically they haven't ever
confirmed but theoretically
they did say that they switched the
thing because they wanted to release in
spring right
i mean yeah it's not coming out november
because you have like four seasons of
stuff to do so yeah there's no way it's
any sooner than 12 months
so and that by that logic they should be
announcing it soon
typically they have a six-month cycle
which means that in august or september
they should be announcing when did we
get info on which queen stuff i can't
even remember the time
it's usually over the summer but when
did
this over the summer before it comes out
yeah we did get it around the summer
yeah because it was i think which queen
we got sooner because it got delayed so
probably delay june or something april
june um
so the question is when do we get uh
destiny's for
may fourth major expansion is coming
february 22nd that's news on august 24th
yeah exactly i mean it would be i think
i think we'll be on light with similar
so
uh my theory is
and i think we've all talked about this
that it's going to take them 18 months
to do every expansion right and that
we're going to be waiting a little bit
longer than we think we are
[Music]
so do you think they announce it next
year
in the spring or do you think they we
get an announcement and some stuff about
lightfold this year do you think they're
going to move that quickly
i don't think we hear anything about
lightfall until the calendar says 2023.
really
i don't really why so why so so why not
early i'm just i want to hit the
opposing side why part of it would be is
if they're trying to have
part of it for me would be like maybe
almost like selfishly narratively
if lightfall has a big moment to it that
has some buildup in previous seasons we
don't want to know what's going to
happen
towards the end of season 19 before we
even get 18. because 18 is going to drop
august 23rd
theoretically i don't want to hear about
lightfall august 22nd
that's i mean we did do that last time
last time they did tell us about the
upcoming but that was coming like
november and then it got delayed but
yeah
but february 22nd is the article you
just read right
february 22nd is when the date was and
it came august 24th so yes that's why
i'm saying that's what they did before
so
that's why i said selfishly narratively
i was like sure i wouldn't mind that but
also
i don't know if they know when they're
gonna be able to drop it yet i don't
know how big lightfall's gonna be i
don't know the scale of what they're
trying to build i don't know if there's
like i mean
if it's gonna be
i mean if you do if you have hive
guardians in which queen do they do
something along those lines is this the
time they get rid of champions like i
don't know what systems they would go
after in a lightfall so i don't know how
much time they would want so i mean if
you think of 18 months that's going to
push it from february to
august
of 23 that's a long
that sounds no it wouldn't be august
they did like a three what did they do
15 months they pushed it the last season
okay so that would be
march april may
yeah forgetting the key factor money
the sony checks going clear
that's
but if anything the sony acquisition
will make it come slower
put
number one sony takes forever to make
games that's part of their culture they
let their studios take a long time so
they're not really gonna be the type to
push it out the door number two sony has
said that they basically want to
braindrain bungie and take them off of
destiny to go we're bringing the brain
reminds me of
what is that batman forever with uh jim
carrey
pretty good they they want to take uh
bungie's employees and their brain trust
and make them work on a bunch of
different live service games i i
honestly think that that's going to be
hugely detrimental to destiny's
development uh i i know you guys
disagree on that but i still stand by
that and and we will see three
even if even if sony was like dude we're
giving you all this money just so that
you can
you know higher up and staff up which by
the way isn't happening the the money is
going to the shareholders and the people
that own the business they're hiring
people in there constantly
but they were before they got acquired
by sony and
when you hire people that doesn't
necessarily mean all those people are
working on i never said it is for the
nearest thing that it's going to improve
but they are hiring a ton of people if
you watch like all the all the threads
that i see i can't tell you how many
people i've seen are like first we get
bungee
all the time there's a that's a lot of
staff constantly for one student
now go through your head and remember
all the people you've seen post today's
my last day at bunji
i haven't i don't know i don't follow
i've been on that many no i've seen it
as much as i've seen today's my first
day i've seen you know i've not seen
that that much
i i defer to you guys i don't believe no
it's like i've seen so many i've seen
way more way more like this is my first
day at bungie versus my life i honestly
can't think of that because i was i was
connected to a lot of the old guard
because that was when i was going maybe
yeah maybe
but yeah i i see it just as much so i i
don't know if they're adding a lot of
staff i i bet you that they're i bet you
they're adding some but i don't think
it's like there's a very large amount of
retention bonus right now so i don't
think they're losing that many
the retention the retention is to stay
at sony not to stay at bungie which is
why i think there's going to be a brain
drain from bungie i think they're going
to go work on other sony projects well
next time we have live service games in
five years
10 live service games in five years if
they consider gran turismo live service
they need to get their
stuff together
yeah it's like i'm not touching that
sony franchise because they've been
leaving check going clear it's gonna be
nice
what do you think because we're both on
i'm not gonna hear about light bulb
before 2023 just because
i don't know because if they put that
date all the way out to like
may
i mean even like game awards is the
soonest i'd see it at that point which
is technically like december you know
late december but so when when do we
think uh life was dropping again what
was it i mean what do you if you go 15
months like it was for witch queen then
that would be may because if you go july
you know february 22nd or whatever that
date was go 15 months it'd be may 22nd
it'd be no way it's may
when do you think later i think i think
it's fall of next year oh wow oh oh wow
wow i don't okay so they pulled out the
30th anniversary to fill a gap in season
of the loss right i don't know if they
have another one of those two that's a
tremendous gap to fill a hole
maybe the sony infusions like
we're good we're comfortable
but also like can you have
a nine month season do you do that do
you do the last season
and i think they just add seasons
but then the live season what the live
service is now making
okay but we haven't paid for that though
is that going to be an additional charge
now for the bonus season because i paid
for all of years for content season 8 16
17 18 19.
could be free seasons could be
uh part of what you get if you pre-order
the new thing that they haven't come out
with yet
we'll give you the two seasons
yes you know there's stuff like that i
i don't know man it just 15 months seems
so fast like i feel like we just got
done playing witch queen but i mean that
thing's been in development for a while
if you look at whatever what was the
aerograph from gdc or something yeah it
was like
in development pre-pre-pre-developed
yeah it's like
that stuff's going for a while i don't
know like
i would probably say may
even if it's like may june that's that's
a long time for however they spaced
their seasons
um yeah that's a long time and then that
that would assume that there is going to
be like another season of the
risen no what what was the one that's
the result last was the sixth this is a
law that's gonna assume that there's
another season of the lost like delay
right so i don't know if it's that long
i don't know if it's that long
uh ah
that means that would be over a year
over a year since which queen
for it's gonna be over a year no matter
what it was over a year from beyond
light to lightfall yeah travis was
there's a delay with the delay though
right with a delay that that kind of
slowed things down for them but do you
think
the only time they've ever successfully
released
destiny content with a year turnaround
was under activision which everyone
who's worked at that company says was
unsustainable had to grind a ton all
this other stuff and they were not
working remote
right right they're not dealing with all
of the coveted stuff that happened
right in the middle of the development
of lightfall right like all this stuff
just makes me think that like
if they pull it off
a year to 15 months i will be incredibly
impressed but i look around at all the
game delays that are happening
oh yeah no it's real everything it makes
me feel like there's just no
way that a company that is
calling itself remote first is moving at
that speed because i have also started
working for a remote first company since
covid and everything moves slower
it's possible it just would be
surprising to hear it to say like okay
we're not getting a new expansion
theoretically until may of of next year
that's a long time that's a long time
and then you have to put seasons in
between you see the problem they have is
they still have to supplement
content
with a delay
they're not free like other games other
games can delay and say work on that
content that you've delayed no they have
to give us something
yeah
but that's that's when you'll get wrath
of the machines that'll hold you
i mean we've been over this debate
before though at some point do they
actually have to supplement that delay
with something else they pulled the 30th
anniversary out of their bodies
but
you're just going to make up another
season it's not about just making up
we're forgetting fiscal years y'all they
gotta they gotta make money they gotta
give us something that we have to buy i
will take to help keep the lights on i
know i get all of this believe me i'm
very curious how this journey goes
because i can see it
at some point for them
they need to be able to just like focus
up but as you said the live service you
can't but then you're asking people to
pay for this like
bonus expansion pack as a filler thing
what did like and they they did that
once are they gonna be able to get away
with it again with the 30th anniversary
since some of the horse stuff you know
the star horse stuff was kind of free to
some people but then we got grasp of
avarice gallihorn by the way i i am not
saying that i don't think that they'll
not be able to hit a year because like
they're slow or whatever i know you're
not saying that you just don't i think a
year is unreasonable
i think a year is unreasonable for a
mainline expansion if they want
unreasonable
i do i think it's too it's too little
time
think
like god of war is going to be four
years if it hits this year
it's way too quick i i disagree how long
did halo take six
it was like seven years yeah i mean they
they put out content faster than most
anybody so again we're we're knocking on
them for being like oh it might be 15
months they're like can you guys
not i mean granted it's not like a full
game they added that's what i was about
raid it is the scale of what they build
again so that may be the point where
travis what you're saying is how much do
we get for an expansion yeah and that
might be the question is how much do we
get
yeah there's other there's another
component i've been thinking about as
well which is that
i i personally think that they probably
will switch to an 18-month release model
i think it'll take them 18 months to do
light fall and then after that they're
going to be like hey
you know final shape is going to be 18
months from now and they'll probably
just stick on that schedule but the
other thing is
even if
they don't release lightful on time they
have something else that they're
definitely going to be announcing today
which is matter they're going to be
announcing that this year they they i
mean one would assume there's more to
higher pr people and stuff we're saying
so you usually don't hire marketing
until you're ready to until you're ready
for product so that's already started to
happen
um
but matter could end up being what they
direct people to
we don't know what that is if it has any
sort of crossover where you bring your
character into something else or it has
some sort of tie-in to destiny we have
no idea i wouldn't doubt there's any
tie-in to destiny so they don't alienate
anybody who's like oh this is a destiny
thing i don't i don't want to get into
that
yeah
they want to expand their franchise and
conquer the world and all this others i
mean that's what you've got
and then again yeah the tv shows have
the same alienating problem
they're gonna make a whole tv show and
then say well you have to have played
destiny right
but i mean i've never played league of
legends but i've heard i haven't watched
it yet but it's like i want to watch the
arcane show on netflix and i've never
played league of legends a day in my
life but i've heard that show is
fantastic if it's done well
but did you watch it i haven't yet but i
was like that's just because i suck at
watching tv and i have way too much
stuff to watch
yeah well i'm kind of the same way but
i'm also like it makes me less likely to
watch it if i haven't played whatever
the source material but that was the
thing i actually heard about that is
like people if i've actually heard the
funny thing is like if you didn't know
anything about league of legends
it actually was better it actually
because they didn't know they didn't
know about it any idea what was going to
happen
the same thing with the witcher so
i don't i don't think that is a block i
think to me the thing that they're gonna
have to worry about is like you said
matter is coming we know the development
cycle we know the pandemic i am very
curious again i know everyone's poo
pooing the sony acquisition but i'm very
curious how much they're going to ramp
up because they got a lot of projects
which requires manpower which requires
hiring so to me
2023 they got to go full tilt with still
supporting bungie support matter and
then all these other projects there's a
reason why you signed this contract
because clearly you didn't feel that you
could do this on your own
you don't see so i want to know when
that hits to your point yes that mashing
out is the other option
that could be the option too but i still
think they believe enough in destiny
when you assign luke smith and whatever
to be the surveyors of the the destiny
cinematic universe you plan on being
around for a long time you know what i'm
saying i don't doubt that i don't think
that i just i
i don't think that their reasons for
signing with sony are the ones that we
think and it's pretty telling when you
read their pr statement and they don't
mention destiny improvements as being a
reason until the very end as like a
throwaway line and everything else is
about how they want to make movies and
and they got big players
music and stuff
that wasn't they wanted to drop a hot
single on music i don't think they're
going to go out there and say
because of the grandiose players you're
not going to sit there and dominate the
press release with one game and talk
about all the things you're going to do
in one game on a press release you're
going to talk about the grandiose looks
how great it is in the long term future
to your point yes there's a lot of other
thing mentioned and we got to hold them
accountable and see if destiny is
sacrificed as a result so to speak i
don't think so i'm going to say that go
ahead okay i can't say it no it'll be
the next topic so finish order okay no
no i was going to say i just don't i i
i'm not on the track train with it's so
evil that they decided so i think it's
going to help the game i think that
they've shown that they i want to i'm
going outside with this i think that
they have shown
by themselves that they cannot support
destiny consistently and with sony's
help yes they're going to be making live
services but you need to hire for that
right and to me that seems like they're
going to get everything that they want
which is the resource to do these
multiple things it's up to them to
execute though i will give you that
i think that they want the
infrastructure
i think that they're
going to lose a lot of their own
employees even if they don't want to i'm
not saying bungie sold because they want
to kill destiny i'm saying that it might
be a side effect where sony is offering
bungie employees higher
money and saying hey you got your
loyalty
uh your loyalty money we set aside for
you guys come look at this other project
that's more exciting
title and uh you know you'll get to
carve your own path and that's super
tempting even if i was working on
destiny and somebody told me that i'd be
like oh that's kind of a good idea like
why not do that and when that happens
then you lose the brain trust that's
working on destiny and that that's
that's what i think will happen but i
don't think it's bungee going oh we're
selling out because screw the players i
just think they're like hey we want the
infrastructure and sony wants our
expertise on live service games and
they're not
taking into account maybe the
repercussions of that the culture that
you lose when you sell your company and
i i think bungie sold their company too
soon because i wanted them to become the
next activision and kind of fill the
void of these large companies that are
being sold off right yeah is probably
going to get by oh i feel you i feel you
and i i just there's no we've got very
small companies and then we've got the
enormous titans but we don't have i know
what you're going to be losing those
middle class
developers i wanted bungie to be one of
those so
anyway i don't know how we got into this
but yeah no no it's good it's a good
discussion the last part i'll say
because i just had this conversation
with maddie on duke and i just think
times are changing man
it's the the video game business is too
expensive to take a loss and i think why
this is why you're seeing the middle guy
take to take the bag because if you mess
up you're out of here destiny is an
anomaly let's just be honest there's
nothing like this this game should have
been dead from 2014. let's be honest
it just won't die it's something about
it they are very fortunate and i just
think this industry that's why you're
seeing all this consolidation in the
games industry and they sat there and
they looked at their long-term options
if they continue at the rate they're
going and with the content rate that
they produce
they probably said this is the better
alternative if we look at the books and
i think that's what's going on here but
look i'm with utrecht uh morally and i
love the idea of the middle guy being
able to sustain and do on his own
i just don't know if it applies in this
this climate in the games industry based
on the way consolidation works i mean
and people being sustainability no
completely disagree yeah we're just
agreed to if anything bungie proved that
they can do it they've been growing and
raising money and they're making all
this money with microtransactions they
were still going to do it you're the one
who doesn't like currencies
and all this other stuff i just bought
leviathan
if they keep he talked about this in the
great state this guy complains about
everything that they reuse they clearly
need help that's my job i'm a critic but
they don't need help
they they literally had just raised
hundreds of millions of dollars
right before the acquisition to improve
the game they were building the new
campus they're doing all this stuff and
i honestly think it's like uncertainty
and the the recession that's probably
coming and other factors like that plus
the fact that the people own it they
probably got a really good offer from
sony uh actually we know they did sony
overpaid probably and uh they wanted to
cash out there's that personal incentive
so i get all the reasons i don't blame
anyone at bungie i don't think sony's
evil i think sony made a super smart
play on this because they need live
services in their background this is
huge because that's the one thing they
suck at doing right they don't have any
online games they're all a single player
um yeah
well single player also known as boring
you can't
really not god damn
this guy
this guy in this window i'm probably not
pointing the right place so maybe this
side is your hashtag just one
this guide's our cynical critic and i'm
somewhere between them you're between
two uh shout out to alex kilgore i have
no idea what we're talking about but i
want more pvp support also take my money
so he's apparently on board for the
journey just please give him some pvp
love question for you guys because the
black wings brought it up
do you think destiny alex just won't say
it yeah you think destiny 2 will be
supported
on ps4 and xbox one through final shape
yes
final shape thought that's what i'm
asking because it's the same engine
final shape is 20 20
well by this matthew
probably august of 2024 if we're going
on this 15-month cycle and that's a a
generous cycle per travis that's
generous that's generous
yeah
i would say it depends on
it depends on the
depends on the chipset because nobody
can't get these consoles they're not
gonna to travis's point they're not
going to do it i actually wouldn't say
i've seen that getting better
right but until it's a consistent
people get
okay so
light fall
middle of 2023
no we still oh yeah we still want to
finally at that point final shape is
probably
but i mean okay but are you gonna do
your last expansion for your ten-year
franchise and leave that
i mean technically they did it with um
what's it called where was that
did they do it then
when did they trap what you call it
support yes for ps4 when they dropped
360 and ps3 support for destiny around
what expansion was it taken care of that
was uh rise of iron it was rise of iron
so that was after that was post-taking
king
an
expansion yep i think it's all analytics
for bungie man that's my that's my
prediction yeah i think they'll probably
play it by ear but uh
the fact that they're supporting so many
platforms and it's sort of the future
right they're also you can play destiny
on the cloud i i know they're not on the
steam deck right now because of
anti-cheap but i assume that they'll
probably get there eventually so
um
i don't i don't think i don't think
until they change their their engine in
that they're gonna do it i don't think
they ever change an engine oh they will
after after um
they have to
you can't change the engine i mean i was
like it's already 17 years it's already
hanging on it's hanging on right now
like i'm i
i hope and believe me it's like i have
my moments between whoever i'm like
chatting with and stuff
i after final shape it's time all right
but here's the question what do we
consider changing the engine that's that
let's let's define that so i i'm clear
what you because both things could
happen define what's changing the engine
to you guys you think you're going to
build a new engine
okay so i bet you they're already
building it so do you think really
reiterating on what's existing and
upgrading that doesn't count like you
you're talking
like a scrap and then it's like
a brand new foundation like how what
what are you defining as a new engine
though i would say yeah from scratch
like i mean you know if you did not
develop god
this is like
this is resistance to
um
horizon zero dawn i think it's gotta be
a
well i don't know if they go unreal five
cause they do love their own in-house
tech and of course you know it's like
that's fine that spaghetti code is very
specific spaghetti i get that but also
at a point when you do end a franchise
then they have a chance to be like all
right your character this guardian can
live here now is that time to go forward
it has to be a full rebuild after that
has two i don't know if it's a full
rebuild or not because i saw the blam
engine for halo get maintained for 17
years
i will say this go ahead fans had better
hope that it's a full relationship yeah
it needs something they should be hoping
that it is it needs it it needs it at
this point and if it's not i don't want
to hear
mr moneybag sony one more time if they
don't do a full rebuild of the engine i
do not want to
this freedom to do whatever they want i
don't want to hear you so the check goes
clear that the checks are coming down
it
it is
i think you're freaking out i think
you're freaking out i think you you you
have your old man i think you looked at
that press release and you you counted
how many times the word destiny and your
keyword finder came up and it came up
one time like they don't care about the
game
no dude it it hurts me because
because bungie was the chosen one
and i wanted to see them
to grow on their own and get to that
level and i believe that they could do
it because i think they have the right
people and they've got the right culture
and they're awesome and when you sell
you lose a lot of that but that's why i
was obsessed and i think they sold for
the wrong reasons
i get it yeah
[Laughter]
had the high ground
i have no problem with sony in this i
have a lot of problems with bungie
sony sony was playing 3d chess man
shakes his hand a cloud
don't you you better give me
just because i have the exact appearance
and personality of bernie sanders does
not mean you guys can treat me in this
manner
i love you i love you
hear them bernie i'll give you that but
that's about it barely i love it i've
seen just about as much sun as himself
if pvp get a revamp under the sony era
oh i'm going to talk
oh i'm going to talk crazy
if he get his ranking system under this
oh boy i would come here with
playstation
i think i'm gonna get my ranking system
anyway but how much do you think that
costs fifty dollars to build you gotta
do any any improvement from 2023 on you
got a bad deal
anytime they add something that you like
will blame sony's money and any time
they add something i like or blame the
money the millions of dollars that they
raised before they sold it
is the residual they'll divide the
currency that's the budget okay okay
that's what you love the most all these
different currencies it's right in your
wheelhouse so
i've never been accused i mean i have
been accused of acting like an old man
but not having old ideas i no your
appearance
would definitely be the defender of life
service and
things in a new way
yeah we're giving you a hard time on
this one because i do feel grumpy that's
true
yeah pessimistic person yes
no mine's more
i think
obviously no acquisition is going to be
immune to
influences of the company that buys them
i get that sony is not going to have
you know zero influence over what bungie
does sure i get that but i also think
you're reading
way too far in and being like okay so
we've got luke and mark noseworthy who
aren't even on the game anymore they're
hiring other teams for this other stuff
and sony has a production for whatever
they do there's going to be like a
collaboration of people above the people
making the game
it's not going to be like hey we need
tom that we just had on the show and
then we've got justin truman and we've
got joe groth i need you guys to come
over here to sony santa monica and
they're going to strip out bungie or
anything like that i don't see
bungie i don't see bungie trying to run
over destiny with like the sony bus and
i also don't see sony trying to screw up
the one live service that they've
actually got that's the other thing is
sony has like this is the one that
currently is working
we need to try and maintain that one and
still build it and contain it
to be so eventful
saying that sony is going to do any of
that intentionally i'm saying that it'll
happen organically organically part of
the same company now and sony's going to
be like hey we have this new exciting
project do any of you guys want to come
work on it and have a better job title
this other development studio and that's
how it happens it's sort of just like a
a gradual hey it's all in the family
let's move out but then after a while
you realize that none of the same people
work on the game and uh i i do not think
sony's evil here i think sony is playing
a very smart game i like them as a
company if anyone was going to acquire
bungie i would have had it be sony i
just didn't want anybody to acquire i
wouldn't like microsoft hang on
you wanted to be microsoft
i would never have guessed i would never
have guessed the lord
cognito of the phil dominus maximus
aurelius spencer i just like that
feeling relationship and worship would
have liked to see microsoft declare
bungie would never have
you're absolutely right for clowning but
here's the thing
i like what executives gave and i like
when the executive's favorite game is
destiny so it's like yo let's do it
let's go i don't know
i know phil plays
that is pretty dope i'll give you that
oh yeah question for you the reason i
would have chosen sony is because i
think they need bungie the most yes they
need i don't know if it's xbox wouldn't
know what to do with bungie i think that
they would just say hey we're already
doing this so you guys just keep doing
what you're doing
well attic has a question for trap can
bungie have been their own riot games if
they grind enough he wants to hear what
travis has to say
uh i wouldn't use that company as an
example because yeah they have some
games
they have some problems but yeah i i
think they could have become like the
new
2k
uh type studio the new uh you know
ubisoft or ea because there's going to
be a void of those types of studios with
all these massive acquisitions and no
one's feeling it right now it's sort of
like the death of the middle class like
the death of the middle developer
publishers kind of happening in slow
motion
in the industry and so i i i saw i saw
bungie seizing the opportunity when they
were announcing that campus building and
all the other stuff all these hires that
they were doing before the sony
acquisition i saw them filling that void
uh in the coming years with matter
hopefully being a hit and you know them
doing other stuff and expanding the
franchise i i was i was
dreaming of that future and it was sort
of just you know they sold out too early
i think you always want to sell your
company but i think you sell it
eventually and i think they sold it
a little too early and what is that
they spent a year apologizing to us
pardoning their dust because they had
just gone through all of the effort of
being independent we're an independent
we have this vision for an independent
bungie and an independent future and
they were they were selling us the dream
and then they gave up on the dream
before i mean you literally said sony
overpaid for him they made him on offer
they just couldn't refuse it
i think budgies
[Music]
sony sony made a great call they bought
the right company it was a good price if
i was a shareholder bungie i probably
would have voted for it too i get all
the reasons but you can still be
disappointed
he said that he said ryan had a lot of
successful games you think bungie would
have made successful games like like
riot did if they would account for that
format okay hell yes
i think their biggest issue is that they
were figuring out their new identity
post halo and that they were getting ips
under their belt that they owned but i
think that bungie's incredibly talented
and if they would have stayed
independent and kept the culture that
they have which is
let's face it one of the best cultures
events oh for sure
i think i think that they could have
become that successful um and that being
on their own they're still going to be
successful i just think that they they
could have done it in a way where they
could have controlled more of the
industry and more of the conversation um
instead of instead of selling at the
point i will say i just think they sold
too early they should have sold 10 years
from now so i will say what cog is
saying that was like the middle level
developer is in a hard spot
because
you've got
big guys obviously looking at
acquisitions little ones who have you
know they'll work with some of the
smaller publishers like annapurna
devolver and those type of ones we
usually have some good stuff that come
through them and they curate those
bungie being in the position that it is
and i this is where i wonder if
something like a cyberpunk will scare a
studio because like what if matter
doesn't hit
what if you flop
yeah out of here and that's what can and
financially it's like that's part of one
of those times where if they look at
that and it's like we want to be
independent but then they see something
like cyberpunk go
and almost cause that company i mean
it's not done because obviously they're
making witcher 4 but it hurt
big time and for
and that's one of those things i wonder
if that's even a factor in there if it
plays in
but i mean when you say the middle
people are kind of going away it does
if you get big enough to be noticed
you're also now you have a target on
your back at the same time and it's
tough but i was like but people used to
hold out
i mean i get that and ubisoft did and
now they're worth way more than they
were when all those people were trying
to buy them yeah they had also a whole
bunch of chaos going inside their studio
too so i also don't think that there's
as much danger as you were presenting
for matter because you know what other
game flopped when it came out destiny
and you can fix a game bro when it flops
if you've got time into it you gotta
admit destiny is like a miracle story
exactly how they fixed of how they fixed
and people even still care like but
that's normal now
i don't know what live stream even
cyberpunk dude cyberpunk had a had a
refresh this year and i'm i'm actually
currently in the middle of a playthrough
for cyberpunk because it's a very good
game now so i mean kevin
kevin and chad mentioned gearbox
they've
they've had some i mean they tried to do
battle was it battleborn that one
definitely
i would argue the gearbox problem was
culture-based i mean randy has a whole
different problem in there yeah that guy
seems like a train wreck and a half but
i don't think they had that i don't
think they had the same talent and
culture but it's like that's that's that
weird little that's not little but
that's that
level where they that those debates okay
we are strong enough we have the cash
flow coming in let's try and make it
matter that flops that's a lot of
investment to see
like crash 100 and i would throw their
own words back at them and say be brave
yeah that sounds nice but like i said
and then take a look
on top of that take the pandemic on top
of that
now just like the financial risk of
everything else like yeah take the
financial risks of just what that does
to everybody now jobs are a little
harder to come by things are wages
everything it's just a combination of a
lot of things and timing i know i i i
acknowledge that that the
socio-economic situation and the
pending recession everybody's kind of
bracing for it i i 100 get it i just i
would love to to be able to step into
this you want to see the multiverse to
see what happens
and i want to see bungie like
revolutionize the industry industry by
leading from the front and i feel like
they can't do that anymore that's all
that's fine
what's your over last question what's
your over under on the relationship
the marriage staying a marriage
i think it'll be fine okay i think they
won the partnership association i think
yeah i think bungie won that i've never
heard of a contract like that like
that's i've never seen sony not make
those get like the fact that destiny
wasn't
exclusive i knew it was a lot but
that that was a big deal and like they
they were bold in these statements and
they're still kind of boring did that
happen after activision
wait oh what as far as yeah it happened
like so there was the fear of the yeah
yeah there's the fear of the ftc for the
activision saying and then activision's
like oh call of duty is going to be on
all platforms and i guess that could
have been one of those things to like as
possible smooth a little bit but also
i mean i guess i think bungie won the
negotiation big time i mean for sure i
think i think it was because bungie won
the negotiation and they said look if
we're gonna do it we're gonna do it this
way right because we have no need to
sell we're not uh
like activision we're not getting passed
by we're not getting sued by the state
of california and attacked by our own
employees uh publicly so they they did
not feel the need so they were just like
look you're going to pay us way too much
a lot of that's going to be for employee
retention and we're going to be able to
have full control and sony was desperate
enough to get into the industry of live
service that they said fine i think
that's why that's why if this
relationship doesn't work then no
relationship with bungie will yeah like
this is they got
yeah i agree like they got everything
they asked for it's like overpaying sony
gets yeah i completely agree with that
and i don't think i don't think
microsoft would have done the deal as i
don't think would have paid that yeah i
completely agree that's why to your
point it is the perfect fit even though
selfishly i would have liked microsoft
this makes more sense and this
relationship is better for bungie
just keep that in mind when uh destiny
becomes sony exclusive
now
just kidding i don't think so i don't
think so um but yeah i mean for this
obviously when i never this is one of
those random times i'm like there's
nothing to talk about and we are an hour
and 45 minutes so it's
we get off on tangents and
hopefully you guys enjoy the shows
we made it hot i mean it was fun that's
the whole point
uh we don't have anything to talk about
in the 12 right
no
freelance trials this weekend freelance
trials that's it cool
that's literally it noise please make
that permanent that's all i gotta say
just make that stuff permanent yeah
please oh i will i will say oh yeah
sidearm's gonna get fixed no there was
one uh alex kilgore dropping these super
chats he's like for travis
that was one of them and then like
what's the time frame for you to see
bungie
for bungie and sony do you see it
lasting longer than microsoft or shorter
or he expects them to break up with
their
yeah we just answer it i don't think
that they will yeah yeah
i think this relationship can't work
then yeah i i could see maybe in 10
years some of the key bungee employees
like luke smith or pete parsons going
off to
start their own company but i don't
think it'll be bungee i i think uh i
think bungie's going to be sony's
the other question that i saw a little
bit of language and a little bit of a
jab
so we got to keep this kind of short
travis you can't go off the rails
there's a reason why
uh get that bird seed ready trials of
osiris freelance is back the first
freelance trials of osiris weekend for
seasonal hunters is on the way which
means more opportunities to check out
the ultra competitive pvp mode for any
that are conscious or curious about what
it has on your face
repeat that no no repeat that sentence
which means more opportunities to check
out the ultra competitive pvp mode for
those that are curious about what it has
to offer
i love his disgust i can't lie
i get joy when you get mad at certain
things
you have the best upset faces or
something
[Laughter]
i just
really disagree
i have no words for that ultra
competitive traffic that's how they
envision it man i would call it
uh
it is ultra competitive and that you are
competing with their terrible
matchmaking system that's really the
it's the it's a pve mode where you're
playing against the
the computer that's
that's putting those terrible games
together uh
yeah i don't know man they need to redo
we've talked about a million times i'm
not i'm not i'm i'm 100 okay with
freelance i just think that they
if trials isn't going to be the
the the truck in a ranked mode skill
based matchmaking situation then then
they need uh they need a mode that does
do that and i don't care if it's trials
or not i just
yeah that's right gloria i was like
freelance should be permanent and then
the flawless pool should get the hell
out of here both of those because if
last week i don't know if you guys saw
that when or whenever yeah gcx and like
the amount of like
the amount of people who went flawless
didn't change
with and without the flawless pool or
something everybody's like huh what do
you know i remember seeing all the pvp
people tweeting that when i was like hey
just get rid of the falls pool put
freelance in there
put it there all weekend some people
were worried about dividing it but
geared to the falls pool and you got
three you should it should be three
stacks or flawless you should not be
able to go in as a two that's just my
opinion
interesting
so get a team or just you know hightail
it to freelance get the solo oh yeah
that's a happy medium travel like that
yeah all right let me stop i'm about
poking a bit i just submitted my ultra
competitive uh resume to become the ceo
of microsoft so
it's really really competitive
i'm super competitive for that position
got all the qualifications
i like this i like this
well uh next week it sounds like we'll
hear a little bit about grand masters
and some of their plans for the future
uh as for next week let me look at the
calendar next week we've got tony we got
ill physics coming back on the show
the illusion so we're gonna have a good
pvp chat which should be fun uh so spend
a little time in trials after that we
got amaze
home of the vibes coming on the show
host of gcx's main stage
then we've got crit buff
just got featured at by bungie i think
she shouted last week great guy lives in
hawaii um serves in the military i can't
remember so and honestly didn't know if
we were ever going to get him on and
he's got his first day of like weeks of
vacation in forever
uh and then got a couple other big ones
but i gotta get the times
yeah we got we got a couple good weeks
in a row and uh definitely some fun
guests for you guys coming up so
stay tuned uh make sure you guys share
the podcast to anybody who's looking to
hear anything about destiny
tell them tell them about us um if you
guys enjoy the show drop a like on the
channel if it's on my youtube channel if
it's on iron lord's podcast if you guys
are on spotify if you guys are on itunes
leave the reviews the likes however you
guys can support us there it's always
appreciated uh but as we wrap up
that's mostly all i got you gentlemen
have anything yeah we do an outro shout
out yes but i want to shout out the chat
like we got over 100 in here
and i remember you know saying like two
to four
you know six and people still here on
the outro so salute to everybody the
support is real we feel the love again
everyone at gcx that came up to us feel
the love and i started to see more
people you know recommend us and and say
hey give us a shot and i do think we
have a very informative and entertaining
podcast so yeah man salute to the last
word and the homies but uh chad what's
going on with you man do some outros
what you just got you got going on yeah
uh look out for my outriders world
slayer review on monday morning preview
of endless dungeon also on monday
morning
and other content on ign you can also
watch me on sunday mornings on a show
called bitcast where i hang out with
industry vet ames a
gamer lawyer named hogue and a stock
photo of a man who lives in a trailer
park um
quite a good show you can um you can
come and watch that if you want and
other than that you can follow me on
twitter at thai guy travis thanks for
watching everybody
no doubt no doubt e
uh for me i'm gonna work on starting my
only cavs website so i'll be working on
that
road crazy big crazy you got it yeah
it's also spelled calves by the way it
is c-a-l-v-e-f
so yeah spelling was correct even though
i got called out so i just uh
i got only ties so hey there you go
what's yours yes i just wear a tie
but biceps
only guns
yeah only biceps there you go yeah
only only flex
no yeah i will be
um i am getting kind of my preview stuff
ready for
world slayer as well i'm gonna be kind
of getting a little jump on that one
probably will stream
after we do the story stuff next week
i'm guessing i'll probably switch over
and do that so that'll be most of
because i think that's
that is the 28th that's tuesday right
yeah so i think it should be safe to
play after we get done with the story so
you guys will see outriders and honestly
if you haven't ever checked out
outriders
for one it was free i don't know if it
still is please go play it for free the
first part of the game is they worked
out the bugs over the course of the past
year now you're gonna get more of it so
i have
i've i had about 50 hours of a ton of
fun
ran into issues with friends and things
like that but i think after this year if
you haven't played it before and you're
like huh what's this
it's worth your time it's a lot of fun
pretty cool it's got some stuff that
destiny should even be doing still
that's in there so true
especially now we bought this yeah i'm
not allowed to talk about it yeah i know
it's yeah
hey i was gonna ask if they got any new
achievements damn it
let's look actually i have to give my
underscored impressions oh okay yeah
okay
probably not on the 20th yeah
so
um
i can tell you that
i've played the game in its entirety
okay and it is a very good
expansion on the end game and the stuff
you can do
and the levels you can customize your
character and increase your power level
and all that stuff um it's also
noticeably less buggy than the other
ones but it's also bad
in all of the ways it was bad the
original one like it it sort of doubles
down on on everything like the jump
across loading screens and stuff like
that type of stuff like the uh the
terrible story continues to be terrible
yeah you know that sort of stuff uh just
like all the ways that like you you were
like oh they could improve that they
were like no we're just gonna make the
stuff that was good even better and the
stuff that's bad is going to continue to
be bad and so it's sort of uh it's a
little bit weird but yeah i quite uh
enjoyed my time with it so far and i
think i'll play it after it comes out
too a little bit because yeah i played i
played with like my girlfriend stuff and
they're into it so if you guys are
online hit me up and i'll i'll take you
through trials of taurea guitar
oh wait is it actually called no that's
the trials of target guitar
it's uh it's a uh that's the name of it
yeah it is a uh it's it's basically a
raid uh
boss fights and some of the bosses have
mechanics mechanics figure out yeah okay
yeah that's pretty cool yeah a little
little miss seasonal flow i might have
to jump up in there
okay it's pretty fun i'll play with you
it's got also got cross play across
platforms so yes
he bounces and stuff i love it yeah it
did have cross play so yeah that's what
i'll be doing um keeping up with the
story and the bobble heads and soloing
dungeons and lost sectors and
whatever else is going on i'll see if i
get some trials in this weekend since
it's freelance probably get some
reputation there
what about you last but not least doing
this in a different order
iop brother go check it out sunday's the
launch day king will be back we'll
probably have jess cornyn of windows
central on we're gonna be talking a
little techy stuff little fx and super
resolution and you know talk about
what's going on and all these games and
stuff like that and um
we got that going on again look out for
a potential saturday stream to be tmnt6
player with the lord's gonna try to give
you something there and um yeah come
check out our defining duke man it'll go
free freeze on sunday we recorded it uh
fun episode we got some stuff cooking me
and maddie man so yeah check check that
out i know lords of gaming that man i
really appreciate the support of the
articles and things that we're doing
there and uh yeah man you know me at
cognito on twitter all that good stuff
like retweet you know the podcast the
last
bulletin board with all of your stuff
because it's just like
you have so much stuff it's always crazy
yeah you have to especially when you
interview people like you have to be
ready you know what i say oh no like i
know you do but i always hear some
people like do an outro on a podcast and
it's like oh yeah find me i'm like yeah
you got you don't have the practice of
cog over he's got this like whole spiel
things places websites four different
podcasts he's everywhere so absolutely
appreciate it
i'm gonna get this thing under two hours
so for the last word number 203 thank
you all for being here it has been
the last